the crisis at our southern border
spiraling out of control with a
record-breaking number of illegal
crossings every single month and now the
biden administration is reportedly
weighing reinstating former president
trump's remain in mexico policy here now
to react is retired acting ice director
and fox news contributor mr tom homan
good morning to you tom
good morning good morning why do you
think they're weighing this light
version of the remaining mexico policy
that trump had stated why would they why
are they interested in that now is it
because the poll numbers are bad
well that's that's the biggest reason
look it's this past month is going to be
over 200 000 again they haven't
announced it yet but it's going to be
over 200 000.
they haven't announced it they're trying
to figure a way to spin it but they
can't they can't survive this they can't
take this beating every month i'm sure
there's people at the white house that
that are not an idiot that realize that
look this is going to hurt us in the
midterms so understand this first of all
they're going to reinstate your main
mexico program at least they're supposed
to because they were ordered by the
courts to do it i've been involved with
three lawsuits things like i i wrote
i've written more affidavits suing this
president than i did during my entire
career we won the we won the moratorium
on deportations we won the ice
priorities lawsuit and we won the
remaining mexico program these people
have to be ordered by the courts to do
their job and what's the first thing
they do they appeal the decision because
they want to continue doing what they're
doing but i'm convinced there's people
in the white house are saying look this
is bad this isn't working we're going to
lose the midterms and probably the white
house if we don't change policies and
control the border there was a guy
that's been on fox several times his
name's brent smith he's a rancher in
kenny texas and he says he's had to
spend 60 000 to repair the fences on his
property he said he found three bodies
in the area last week he says if you
don't have a gun you're going out on
your own risk he says we can't even walk
in our backyards even during the
daylight what are some of the stories
you've heard down there
i talked to one sheriff last month that
found 48 dead migrants in his county
alone 48 that's one county out of out of
hundreds of counts on the southwest
border the the thing i hear the most is
about
right now is the missing families right
they over a hundred and twelve thousand
children have entered this country
illegally that was the highest number in
the history of the border trail they
released thousands of family units that
came out last week that about 40 percent
of those family units can't be found now
they attacked the trump administration
for 2500 family separations but in the
meantime they got 45 000 children they
can't find this is inhumane policy
children are dying women are getting
sexually assaulted the records of
mountain fentanyl from this country's
cause over 90 000 overdose deaths and
and they're not doing a thing about it
they have to be ordered by the courts to
do their job and secure the border
they're not doing it for the right
reasons they're not doing it because you
want to save lives they're not doing it
they want to help the border patrol
they're not doing it secure the border
they're doing it for their political
future that's the only reason they're
considering on changing some of these
policies at all what do you mean by that
they want texas and arizona some of
those these other states to turn blue
they want to they're afraid they're
going to lose the midterms because the
board of crisis this is about politics
this isn't about doing the right things
in the country they're looking at some
of these policies to get back to some of
the other trump policies because of the
election it's about their political
future not the safety and security of
our country yeah and then you've got the
afghanistan problem what do you expect
in the midterm elections
look
let's leave that let's not leave the
afghanistan problem this is the border
is more vulnerable now it's ever been
right we already know it 40 percent the
border patrol is not on the line they're
dealing with family units that's why the
fentanyl is coming across that's why you
know 1.3 million encounters already on
the border
thousands of terrorists have been
released from the prisons afghanistan
whose sole purpose in life is to do harm
to this country if you're a terrorist
you want to come to this country do us
harm if you can't get a plane ticket you
can't get a visa because of the checks
we've done since 9 11. you're going to
come across the southwest border the
same way 20 million others did it's very
scary i read a story this morning that
thousands of them have been deemed at
risk the ones that we have taken in from
afghanistan thank you so much tom for
being on with us